In problem set number 4, you will be implementing a parallel algorithm
for removing the red eye effect that commonly occurs in pictures of human faces.
Here is an example of the effect that we are talking about.
You will be implementing a simple algorithm for red eye removal
that factors nicely into 3 different parallel operations.
The first operation is a stencil computation over the image,
the second is a sort, and the third is map.
You have been exposed to map and stencil operations in the previous homework,
so in this homework, you will focus on sorting.
We start our red eye removal algorithm
by computing a score for each pixel
that estimates the likelihood of that pixel belonging to a red eye,
and here's what the score looks like.
This score is known as normalized cross-correlation,
and it is expressed naturally as a stencil operation.
We have computed this normalized cross-correlation square for you,
but if you're interested we will provide extra details about normalized cross-correlation in the Instructor Comments.
Our next step is to sort all of the pixels in the image
according to their score.
Note that the pixels with the highest scores
are the pixels that most likely belong to a red eye, as you can see here.
This sorting step is what you will be implementing in problem set number 4.
If you are interested,
we will discuss several different types of optimization strategies for sorting in the Instructor Comments.
Our final step is to reduce the redness of the high scoring pixels.
This computation is expressed naturally as a map operation.
Once again we've performed the step for you so you can concentrate your efforts on sorting.
That is all, good luck and I hope you will enjoy problem set number 4,
and like the previous problem sets I want to thank Eric and Mike
for writing the code and the script to this problem set,
so thank you.